but we begin with our top story this
hour the go ahead for a second
covet 19 vaccine last night the food and
drug administration granted emergency
authorization to modernise vaccine
an initial batch of 6 million doses will
begin shipping out this weekend
modernist says
it hopes to make up to a hundred million
doses available in the u.s
by march it comes one week after the
approval of pfizer's vaccine which is
already being administered
errol barnett was the first to report
that some vials of
the pfizer vaccine contained extra doses
that was enough to vaccinate even more
health care workers and staff
at one cleveland hospital
this was the moment cleveland's metro
health hospital had been desperately
waiting for
with lieutenant delmar henderson
escorting the first batch of
pfizer's vaccine once thawed and mixed
with a saline solution
they were ready to begin vaccinations
critical care
doctor sherry williams was first in line
she's still witnessing the painful
impact of the country's worst pandemic
in a century when is the last time you
lost a patient to covert
yesterday and this morning
and what toll does that take on on you
guys it's exhausting
and it's heartbreaking quite honestly
it's heartbreaking
young people old people
people that i'm just now meeting
and watching their families be
devastated families like that of nurse
david bilac who works in the covert wing
my grandfather he ended up passing in
july from
complications related to kovid his
grandfather was being treated on belac's
floor
while he was slipping away not even my
grandmother was it wasn't able to see
him
i mean they were able to zoom zoom call
what's striking to me is that every
person we've spoken to who has received
the vaccine has either
lost someone to the pandemic or there's
a relative they desperately want to see
but there is a sense that this could be
a real turning point and there's so much
optimism because of it
you know this is what we've all been
looking for and hoping for hope was
amplified as cbs news witnessed dr
brooke watts and her team trying to
confirm something
totally unexpected each vial
was meant to be fi was originally
labeled for five doses there are six
full doses in each vial at least this
means hundreds more
doctors nurses and support staff here
like custodians and police officers can
get inoculated
folks like lieutenant henderson whose
own family had
doubts do you understand their
reluctance
yes i understand because i was on the
fence
myself recent surveys show black
americans are less likely than other
groups to want the vaccine
although trust overall is increasing but
henderson a former marine
changed his mind when my father said
that's the right thing to do i've been
serving my country
my entire life so what what better way
to serve my country and my community
than this stage right here and receive
this vaccine his dad mike survived
cancer multiple times and suffers with
diabetes
so after being among the first to get
the vaccine at metro health henderson
went for a socially distanced visit
with the man he calls his hero the two
face to face for the first time in
months
i feel i feel good so when the test
coming it's your time
take it but i feel good an extra dose of
wisdom
on a day of special surprises for cbs
this morning saturday
errol barnett cleveland